charisma carpenter is opening up about
her experience working with joss whedon
and now she's receiving support from her
buffy the vampire slayer co-stars
in an instagram post on wednesday the 50
year old actress had this to say
quote josh sweden abused his power on
numerous occasions while working
together on the sets of buffy the
vampire slayer
and angel the disturbing incidents
triggered a chronic physical condition
from which i still suffer
it is with a beating heavy heart that i
say i coped in isolation
and at times destructively i uh
just wish i could be there to see it
carpenter was a regular cast member on
buffy the vampire slayer
before her character moved to the
spin-off angels starring david boreanaz
in 1999.
whedon was an executive producer on both
series
she goes on to allege whedon quote
proceeded to attack my character
mock my religious beliefs accused me of
sabotaging the show
and then unceremoniously fired me the
following season
once i gave birth it's not very sharp
and i'll have to put some muscle behind
it shortly after carpenter's comments
were posted
her buffy co-star sarah michelle gellar
released a statement on her instagram
writing quote while i'm proud to have my
name associated with buffy summers
i don't want to be forever associated
with the name joss whedon
the 43 year old actress added that she
won't be making any further statements
at the time
but quote i stand with all survivors of
abuse and i am proud of them for
speaking out
if you're going out why don't you take
your sister
mom another buffy co-star michelle
trachtenberg
later reposted the message to her
instagram and thanked geller for
speaking out
and called whedon's behavior quote not
appropriate
in carpenter's statement on wednesday
she credited actor ray fisher for
helping her come forward with her own
story
if these are gifts why am i the one
paying for them
in december warner media concluded its
investigation into whedon's alleged
misconduct
stemming from rey's allegations about
joss's behavior
on the set of justice league the 33 year
old actor claimed the director was quote
abusive and unprofessional
the corporation said in a statement at
the time remedial action has been taken
adding there are still conversations
that need to be had
and resolutions that need to be found et
has reached out to whedon's reps for
[Music]
comment
you